hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
sensitivity selectivity and speed
solving analytical challenges in
endocrinology
using lcms ms for clinical research
presented by dominic foley senior
scientist at waters corporation
i'm benjamin dugas the senior marketing
manager for clinical diagnostics at
waters corporation and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by waters corporation
for more information on our clinical
solution please visit us at watters.com
forward slash clinical
at waters we understand that clinical
diagnostics is more than collecting data
it's making a difference in someone's
life this is why we provide clinical lcm
sms solutions
that you can trust in every step of the
workflow
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation
additionally we will be conducting a few
polls
throughout our presentation and we
appreciate your participation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found on the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits following this presentation
those credits can be obtained by
clicking on the tab at the top
right and follow the process to obtain
your credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dominic foley at waters corporation
dominic foley is a senior scientist in
our clinical scientific operations team
working at waters mass spectrometry
headquarters in winslow uk
dominic is specialized in the
development of lcm sms clinical research
applications
with a particular focus on steroid
hormone analysis
dominic has worked in separation
sciences for 13 years
following his ambition of improving the
quality of health care
for a complete biography on dominic
please visit the biography tab
on the top of your screen with that said
i'd like to hand it over to dominic to
start his presentation
dominic
thank you ben um i would like to welcome
everyone to this webinar today
analytical sensitivity selectivity and
speed
are critical parameters in most
analytical methods
the challenges we observe in
endocrinology research
can be solved by leveraging the
sensitivity
selectivity and speed of lcm sms
technologies
today i want to provide you with an
overview
of how higher sensitivity tandem ms
platforms
can be used to meet the demands of a
clinical research environment
in this presentation on sensitivity
selectivity and speed
solving analytical challenges in
endocrinology using
lcm sms for clinical research
there are three main learning objectives
today
the first objective is to understand the
analytical benefits
of using lcm sms for endocrine
methods over other more traditional
platforms
including amino assay the second
objective
is to show how we can incorporate
selective sample preparation workflows
to improve analytical performance of the
method using lcm sms systems
final objective is to demonstrate how
offline automation
can be leveraged to improve method
performance
and optimize efficiency in lcm sms
labs
first of all i wanted to cover the first
learning objective by discussing the
benefits of using
lcm sms methods over other platforms
particularly in regards to analyzing
endocrinological analytes in
clinical research i will outline the
water's lcm sms
id ivd systems and the capabilities of
these systems
based on analytical sensitivity
requirements
in analyzing endocrine analytes
i will discuss examples of the benefits
of using lcm sms
in endocrinology clinical research
applications
which includes steroid hormones in dry
blood spots
estrogens in serum and plasma catechola
means and metanephrines
finally i will summarize the
presentation to highlight those key
learning objectives
again
now i would like to highlight the key
benefits
of using lcm sms technology in clinical
research of steroid hormones
this slide shows the steroid pathway
which contains many structurally similar
steroid species
using more traditional platforms such as
amino acid
analyzed samples cross-reactivity of
steroids can occur
due to the lack of specificity of the
antibodies being used
this can lead to poorer analytical
precision and accuracy
particularly at lower physiological
concentrations
in addition these platforms although
fast
cannot only analyze a single analyte at
once
leading to increased time and cost
if multiple analyte test methods are
required
the beauty of using mass spectrometry
and its ability to mass
detect is that greater selectivity can
be achieved for these steroid hormones
while also simultaneously analyzing more
than step one steroid hormone at once if
required
as many steroid hormones are isomeric to
each other the use of tandem
ms can improve selectivity even further
by fragmenting a analyse into product
fragments
thus providing detection through a
transition
or multiple reaction monitoring approach
however tandem ms alone isn't infallible
even with this level of selectivity
isomeric
interference can still be observed as
many analytes may share
the same mrn transitions
those analytes highlighted in the same
colours here are examples of this
higher resolution mass spectrometry
would also suffer from the same problems
due to interference from these steroid
isomers
in addition acetones are also detected
using
msms and these can also cause
interference
particularly with those we've analyzed
only two daltons apart
as shown here therefore to attain the
levels of performance required
an additional separation technique is
needed
the technique we use is liquid
chromatography
for many of those analytics highlighted
in the previous slides
that share the same mrn transitions
we are able to separate them based on
their chemical properties
in these examples here differences in
the positioning
of the hydroxyl groups in the isomers
allow separation of the analytes using
uplc therefore
it is critical to use this orthogonal
technique
with tandem mass spectrometry to
minimize interference
in steroid analysis
before i move on to some examples of the
lcm sms technology being applied
to endocrinology research applications
i want to briefly cover the specific
systems
being used for lc msms analysis in this
presentation
here is the family of the waters ivd
systems
for clinical research analysis
the funding foundation of the ibd family
is the acuity uplci class
zvo tqd
which is a reliable robust and
has a proven track record of performance
the mid-tier acuity uplc i-class z-volt
eqs macro
provides excellent sensitivity in a
compact system
and at the head of the family is the
acuity uplc i-class
c-vor tq-xs system
this has replaced his evo tqs system in
the family
and is the most analytically sensitive
tandem mass spectrometer
available
this slide illustrates how we would
relate the performance of these ibd
systems
to the sensitivity requirements of the
classes of endocrine analytes
the xevo tqt sibo tqd system is able to
analyze a number of world characterized
analytes such as cortisol testosterone
and 25 hydroxy vitamin d
the zevo tqs micro system is able to
analyze
these in addition to more challenging
normalize
such as metanephrines catecholamines
and aldosterone which require detection
at lower physiological concentrations
the xevo tqxss is capable of analyzing
all the analytes shown here including
estrogens thyroglobulin and the active
metabolite
125 dihydroxy vitamin d
in order to meet the demands of more
challenging applications
high performance lcm sms
platforms are needed to meet the
requirements of speed
analytical sensitivity and selectivity
mrm and chromatographic selectivity
can be applied in the same manner across
all the acuity uplc
xevo mass spectrometer systems
however a high-end platform such as the
xevo tqs micro
and z-volt eqxs are necessary to avoid
the trade-offs
between sample throughput or speed and
analytical sensitivity requirements
of a method
now i would like to cover examples of
applications where we are striving
for either analytical sensitivity or
speed
while maintaining selectivity of the
methodology using lcm sms
these examples include a range of
endocrine analytes
in either dry blood spots serum or
plasma
dry blood spots are an established micro
sampling technique
providing a low cost approach of
collecting
shipping and analyzing samples for
clinical research
amino acids are used as a primary
testing methodology for dbs samples
in steroid hormone analysis although
rapid they sometimes require follow-up
for confirmation purposes
the focus for an lcm sms method for
steroid analysis in dry blood spots
will be a high throughput method similar
to amino acid
but with the ability to measure more
steroid hormones in a selective manner
faster analysis requires greater
selectivity in sample preparation
with automation of the extraction
providing a robust
and reproducible sample preparation
workflow
the analytical sensitivity of the plc
i-class
and xevo tqs microsystem
will enable analysis down to
relevant steroid hormone concentrations
using three millimeter
blood spot punches
the primary goal of this method was to
examine
17 hydroxy progesterone the 17 ohp
androstenedione cortisol 11
deoxycortisol and 21 deoxycortisol
which are impacted by the 21 and 11
hydroxylase enzymes
in the steroid pathway a reduction in 21
hydroxylase enzyme
leads to elevated 17 ohp 21 dioxide
and androstenedione with reduced
cortisol
a reduction in 11 hydroxyl layers leads
to similar changes to 21 hydroxylase
deficiency
but 11d oxycodone is elevated as opposed
to
21 deoxycortisol
examination of multiple steroid hormone
concentrations
improves our understanding of these
pathways
these steroids are also non-polar making
selective sample preparation strategies
for optimum analytical sensitivity
challenging
therefore introducing a method to remove
matrix of x
is a root forward in this case using
mixed mod
solid phase extraction or spe
where is this mixed mod anion exchange
spe was used for this analysis
previous steroid hormone applications
have used this approach
and it was also adopted in this instance
ion exchange occurs at high ph trapping
acidic interferences
which have been previously shown to
contribute to iron suppression
and background noise on the system
steroid hormones are retained by
reversed phase interactions
and these are looted with increased
organic solvents
which leaves the interference trapped on
the spe
chemistry
this is the summary of the methodology
we adopted to meet the challenge of
analytical speed and selectivity
but achieving a necessary analytical
sensitivity too
sample preparation was automated on the
tcam liquid handler
with three millimeter blood spots being
mixed in internal standard solution
and diluted sp was performed
using the oasis max spe plates
the sample loaded and washed and steroid
hormones are looted
diluted and directly injected onto the
system
separation was performed using the
acuity uplc i class
with this cortex c18 2.7 micron
2.1 millimeter by a 50 millimeter column
with a vanguard pre column
mobile phases were ammonium fluoride in
water and methanol
with a flow rate of one mil per minute
providing a rapid
separation time and sample throughput
tandem mass spectrometry was performed
on the xevo
tqs micro system with mass links version
4.2
utilizing all the technologies available
to us
automation of this spe protocol was
performed
in less than 90 minutes per plate
allowing for extraction of four plates
in a typical working day
a rapid 1.3 minute lcms method
with a cycle time of less than 2.3
minutes
was created with the separation of the
relevant
isobaric steroids including 11
11 deoxycortisol corticosterone
and 21 deoxycortisol this allows for the
analysis of 384 samples in less than 15
hours using lcm sms
this slide shows the typical workflow
you might expect
during a typical day of analysis of four
full plates of dbs
samples
the entire workflow from start to finish
for a single plate
is less than six hours and for four
ninety six wall plates
this can be prepared and analyzed
within 18 hours
proof of concept experiments were
performed for this method that included
linearity analytical sensitivity and
precision
calibration of undustined ion and 11d
oxycodone was performed
from 0.5 to 500 nanograms per ml
and for 17 hp cortisol on 21 dioxide
cortisol
from 1 to 500 nanograms per mil
aloe cues also shown in the chromatogram
here
are based on signal to noise of
peak-to-peak
were 0.5 nanograms per mil for
understand ion and 11 dioxide
and one nanogram per ml for 17
hp cortisol and 21 deoxychords though
in-house dbs samples were also prepared
at
two five fifty and four nanograms per ml
with total precision and repeatability
evaluated
in five replicates over five occasions
total precision and repeatability for
the five steroid hormones
was less than 9.3 percent
demonstrating excellent reproducibility
of the method
across the concentration ranges
so in summary we believe we have met the
analytical challenge associated
with this type of method we obtain
excellent analytical sensitivity
in dbs down to 0.5 nanograms per mil
for the steroid hormones and selective
offline pro
selective offline automated sample
preparation
can improve lab workflows and removes
matrix interference
providing greater sensitivity of the
final extract
rapid separation with a runtime of less
than 2.3 minutes
cycle time enables analysis of four
plates
in less than 15 hours
making this method an ideal candidate
for rapidly evaluating steroid hormones
in dry blood spots for clinical research
next i would like to cover the
analytical challenges associated with
the analysis of
estrogens in serum
the focus for this method is analytical
sensitivity
where guidelines have been issued that
methods require reproducible management
measurement
down to one picogram per mill or three
pico moles per liter
in order to meet this challenge
selective sample preparation is required
using lle or liquid liquid extraction
or spe and the top performing acuity
uplc i-class
and z-volt eq xs system
for best-in-class analytical sensitivity
mobile phase modifiers can improve
analytical sensitivity further
ammonium fluoride additives in the
mobile phase have been shown to provide
significant improvements in analytical
sensitivity for this method
the estrogens themselves are generated
from the androgens
understand ion and testosterone through
the
action of aromatase
the efficacy of aromatase inhibitors can
be studied in clinical research
by examining the changes in estrogen
concentrations
through aromatase inhibitor action on
the pathway
analysis of estrogens at such low
concentrations can be
problematic for less selective platforms
such as immunoassay use of
lcm sms can help overcome such a
challenge
much like the other steroids previously
discussed the estrogens are nonpolar
making again sample preparation a
challenge
for optimum analytical sensitivity
in this instance with analytical
sensitivity the main challenge for the
method
analytical alternative sample
preparation approaches
were evaluated which included
sp and lle with
lle using a combination of different
extraction
solvents for evaluation purposes
typically for ltm sms methods optimum
analytical sensitivity is achieved using
more selective techniques
such as sp analyse and in this instance
both techniques were evaluated
and lle with hexane e philosophy it
was found to provide the highest
analytical sensitivity one
when considering both estrodiol and
estron together
the addition of ammonium fluoride as a
native makes a significant difference
in analytical sensitivity for the
estrogens
compared to mobile affairs with no
additives shown in red
there is a greater than five-fold
increase in analytical sensitivity
in electrospray ionization negative iron
mode
for both estrodiol and astron
so this is the summary of the
methodology we developed to meet the
main challenge of analytical sensitivity
with selectivity important aspects of
the method
are highlighted in blue
sample preparation was performed by
adding internal standards
to 250 microliters of cinnamon
lle with heat exchange phyllo acetate
mixture was added
to the samples and shaken for five
minutes with the estrogens partitioning
into the organic phase
samples were centrifuged and then 700
microliters of supernatant
was transferred to a 96 well plate with
glass vial inserts
this was then evaporated and
reconstituted
the gloss vial inserts in this instance
reduced absorption during evaporation
compared to
polypropylene 96 well plates
separation was performed using the
acuity uplci class
with a cortex phenol 2.7 micron
2.1 millimeter by 50 millimeter id
column
mobile phases where ammonium fluoride in
water methanol
we have a flow rate of 0.3 mils per
minute providing a separation
of estradiol and strong
mass spectrometry was performed on the
ziva tqxss system
providing us with the best possible
analytical sensitivity
for this analysis
the key performance characteristic is
shown here
which is analytical sensitivity
the limit of quantification was three
picogram per mill
or 10 pico moles per liter 11 pico moles
per liter
for easter dial which showed a signal to
noise at p2p greater than 10 and a cv of
less than 20 percent
the limit of detection was one picogram
per ml
with a cv of less than twenty percent
but only signal to noise greater than
five but less than ten to one
the chromatogram here illustrates an
overview of this testing
which demonstrates we are able to
differentiate
between a blank serum sample and a
sample of one picogram per ml
for other performance characteristics
in-house serum qcs
were prepared at 10 75 and 750 picograms
per mil
with total precision and repeatability
evaluated in five replicas
over five occasions total precision
and repeatability for the estrogens was
less than 4.8 percent
demonstrating excellent reproducibility
of the method
comparisons were also performed against
samples
from the cdc hormone standardization
program
and nyquist scheme for easter dial
deming regression and altman bland
analysis
demonstrated excellent agreements with a
minimal bias within four percent
for both sets of comparisons
with only a statistically significant
proportional bias noted
three should dial when compared to the
cdc hormone standardization
program concentrations
certified reference material was also
evaluated in triplicate
over three concentrations and these
return results
within 4.9 percent of the
nominal concentrations provided
so in summary for this particular method
using a combination of selective liquid
liquid extraction sample preparation
ammonium fluoride in the mobile phase
and the xevo tqxs system
we were able to detect one picogram per
ml concentrations
for both estrodiol and e-strong
precision assessments demonstrated
reproducibility of the method
across the concentration range and the
excellent agreement was noted
for external quality assessment schemes
and the final method i would like to
cover today
are the analytical challenges associated
with the analysis
of plasma metanephrines and
catecholamines
as with the estrogens the focus for this
method is analytical sensitivity
where these compounds exist at low
physiological concentrations
the polarity and stability of these
analytes make sample preparation a
challenge
a selective extraction is required
that can remove these ionic polar
analytes from matrix
at lower ph conditions due to their
instability at higher ph
chromatography also becomes problematic
due to this polarity
and an analytical sensitivity cis an
analytical
sensitive system is required to detect
the lower concentrations
so in this case we use the z-vol tqs
micro mass spectrometer
for this analysis
the pathways here show how these
category amines and metanephrines are
generated
in the adrenal gland the metanephrines
are generated from the cataclysmine
through the action
of catechol or methyl transferase
nor that these are structurally similar
species which means that
typical analytical methodologies for
this analysis
such as hplc with electrochemical
detection
or amino acid can suffer from
interference
as discussed previously the use of lcm
sms can overcome these types of problems
this picture also shows the log p
which as you may know is a measure of
the hydrophobicity of the molecule
here we are dealing with molecules that
have negative log p values
which indicates the molecules are very
polar
and means the molecules are eluted early
in the typical
reverse phase chromatography conditions
with issues around peak shape and matrix
effects
in addition the nature of these analytes
makes sample preparation more
challenging
for analytically sensitive analysis
we meet the challenge of sample
preparation through the use of oasis
mixed mod
weak cation exchange spe analytes are
retained by a mixture of reversed phase
and iron exchange retention
but the ion exchange mechanism is a
requirement
for improved recovery and extract
cleanliness
the iron exchange retention mechanism of
this spe plate occurs that's higher than
ph 5. these analytes are ionized at
lower ph
typically below eight meaning that the
region of ion exchange
using this chemistry is between ph's
five and eight
therefore the ph change for maximum iron
exchange needs to be tightly controlled
using a buffer diluent
100 organic wash can be performed to
remove
non-ionic species from the plate and the
ammonites can be eluted in a lower ph
organic illusion
which deactivates the iron exchange
mechanism on the plate
by deionizing the chemistry on the
sorbents
the use of this chemistry also helps
provide us
the use of this chemistry also helps us
avoid the use of
higher ph conditions that can cause anal
analyte instability
in relation to the challenges with the
chromatography
many chromatographic methods for these
analytes involve the use of hydrophilic
interaction liquid chromatography
separations
otherwise known as hylic which can be
challenging to implement maintaining the
ph
of the mobile phase and spe illusion
solvent is critical for reproducible
retention times
in addition the chromatography is very
sensitive to water content
of the extracted sample which is
illustrated in the chromatograms here
with fronting and poor baseline
resolution
as a result of residual water in the
injection solvent
longer equilibration times are also
needed
to replenish the water layer on which
the separation relies upon
this doesn't necessarily fit into most
laboratory workflows
where reverse phase methods are
typically used which is why reverse
phase method
will be preferable for the workflow
ease of use and improve robustness
so this slide shows an outline of the
methodology applied to this analysis
again some of the critical points are
highlighted in blue
sample preparation was performed using
250
microliter the plasma diluted with
internal standard
in ammonium acetate buffer samples were
mixed and loaded directly onto
an oasis wcx micro illusion plates
and washed prior to illusion
the use of macro lotion technology helps
minimize the volume
in the illusion step thus minimizing the
time required for evaporation
samples were reconstituted prior to
injection
uplc was performed using the acuity
uplci class ftm system
with a hss pfp column for retention
and separation of the analytes using
reverse phase chromatography conditions
with mobile phases of formic acid water
and acetonitrile
detection was performed using the zebo
tqs micro mass spectrometer
and now i'd like to show some of the
performance characteristics associated
with this method
we were able to develop a fast and
selective
chromatographic separation using a pfp
stationary phase
which fits into the reverse space
workflow of most laboratories
all analytes separated within two
minutes
potential interferences such as
metformin
midadrene and aldorfa were all well
separated
lloq experiments demonstrated
analytical uh sensitivity limits between
one and ten picons per ml
for the analytes of interest making
quantification of physiological levels
possible
the method was also shown to be linear
for the analytes up to a concentration
of 20 000 picograms per ml
we also looked at provision precision
performance
which was evaluated through the
assessment of in-house qc samples
prepared at 15 30 750 and 1500 picograms
per ml in plasma
inter and introduce batch precision was
examined over six replicates per
occasion over three occasions
with a cv of less than 59.9 for all
analytes across
the concentration ranges with many
of these under 10 cv
so in summary for this particular method
a reverse phase chromatographic method
was employed to provide a rapid robust
separation with baseline resolution of
interferences
an efficient sample preparation method
using solid phase extraction
provides extraction of polar analytes
from plasma
at lower ph in a 96-well plate
micro-illusion format with the option
to automate the method using a lift
liquid handling system in the future
the acuity uplci class evol tqs micro
system
enables detection at low physiological
physiological concentrations
of catecholamines and metanephrines for
clinical research
providing better detection limits
compared to entry-level systems
so in conclusion for this presentation
use of lcms ms systems provides
significant selectivity advantages
over more traditional techniques using
clinical research
use of higher end platforms such as the
tqs
micro and particularly the xevo tqxss
enables users to meet the analytical
sensitivity
precision accuracy and speed
requirements for the methods
selective sample preparation and
chromatographic separation
helps users meet the unique method
challenges
such as removal of interferences polar
retention
and analytical sensitivity while
leveraging
automation of sample preparation
particularly in half replace
environments which can improve
lab efficiency and minimize operator
error
and so before i finish this presentation
today
i would like to thank my colleagues
heather brown
robert wardle chen chen lee and john
donna
who have all been involved in generating
the methods found in this presentation
i've also attached links relating to
collateral for
the methods and also the waters clinical
landing page
at www.waters.com forward slash clinical
where you can find further information
on the waters clinical laboratory lcms
workflow
ranging from sample preparation sample
handling policing
and so i'd just like to thank you for
your attention today
during this webinar and i would like to
now
open the floor to questions
thank you
thank you dominic for this very
informative presentation
so now we'll start the live q a portion
of this webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of
your questions as we have time for we
have time for a few
so let's get started um first
question that came in dominic is have
you looked into the impact of the
hematocrit
effect on the steroids dry blood spot
method
thank you ben so we are aware
of the impact of the hematocrit effect
in regards to dry blood spots um but
this
in in regards to the steroid methods was
not investigated
um we know that dry bud spots is widely
adopted
so the focus was on that particular
matrix
um and we are aware that others sample
or micro sampling techniques uh that
could help negate this effect
could well be adopted within this
methodology too
so they include um so fans or
fixed volume blood spots from capillary
collection type devices
could be used but um we didn't go
into that level of detail in terms of
the hematograph
effect in this instance great thank you
dominic
so another question that came in is have
you examined any micro or nano flow
techniques for this
method for these methods right okay um
no not particularly we haven't uh really
looked at those techniques
um as our goal was to use a standard
floor system
as these are more widely adopted in
clinical research labs
so the aim was to use a fairly standard
uplc setup so any of the methods we do
create
will fit within the workflows of a
typical lab
so in this instance no we haven't looked
at those techniques
okay great thanks and for the second
time i'll take one more question
um can the dry blood spot method be
transferred to plasma or serum based
methods for steroid analysis
um so in answer to that question uh yes
theoretically the main aspects of the
method
can be transferred um but
when doing that sort of transfer protein
binding
uh particularly with the steroids can be
an issue
so that has to be taken into
consideration
robustness and matrix effects have also
have to be considered
which means that any minor changes to
sample preparation
and chromatographic runtime might be
required to mitigate the impact of those
changes
okay great thank you um okay well then
i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for your interesting uh
questions uh the questions we did not
have time for today we will
uh and those who are submitted during
the on-demand period
we will address these by by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
uh we would like to thank dominic foley
for his time today
and his important research we'd also
like to take lab roots
in association with us here at waters
corporation for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
at the close of the webinar we want to
direct everyone to the next waters
webinar that's on june 25th
at 11 a.m eastern time entitled mass
spectrometry
past and present emerging technologies
and strategies for quality management in
today's lab
clinical laboratory so we hope to see
you there and thank you again everyone